Bell star has come down through time as
one of the great anti heroines of the
Old West
she is the Bandit Queen the female Robin
Hood who was quick with her fists and
even quicker with a colt 45 the reality
though was quite different the bell of
history was a battler who made some bad
choices in men ended up twice widowed
with two children and made the most of
the cards she was dealt only to me to
the most violence events in today's by
graphics we go beyond the legends to
reveal the real Belle Starr
[Music]
my Ramaiya Belle surely the future Belle
Starr was born on February the 5th 1848
in Jasper County southwest Missouri with
that fact established drilling down on
the rest of her life becomes far less
certain much of what is accepted is the
stuff of dime novel fiction sorting out
the fact from the fiction here it's been
a bit of a major challenge now we do
know that her father John Shirley was on
to his third wife when Myra came along
that third wife was named Eliza
Pennington Hatfield and she was a member
of the Hatfield family who famously
feuded with the McCoys the couple had
three other children all of them boys
with Myra being the second oldest John
Shirley he was a wheat corn and hog
farmer when Myra was 6 years of age she
sold the farm for a tidy profit and
relocated the family to Carthage
Missouri he invested in real estate
managing to take possession of an entire
city block that housed a livery stable
blacksmith shop a tavern and a hotel
John Charlie he was a slave owner who
has ardently pro-slavery in the
explosive years before the Civil War
tensions they were high between Pro and
anti-slavery forces in Missouri when his
oldest son bud joined an infamous gang
of Confederate sympathizers known as
quantrell's Raiders John he was
extremely proud meanwhile Myra who
insisted that she be called Belle was
growing into a fine young lady her
parents were among the most prominent in
Carthage and she was able to enjoy a
life of semi privilege she attended the
Carthage female Academy doing well in
her studies where she studied languages
mathematics and grammar she was also a
talented piano player who would
entertain guests in the lobby of the
family-owned hotel when he was home from
his raiding expeditions Belle's older
brother bird taught her how to shoot she
became an excellent shot developing a
reputation as a Marx woman that later
fuel her reputation as the Bandit Queen
so Belle was 13 when the Civil War
erupted Carthage found itself as a
central point of hostilities with no
fewer than 13 battles being waged in the
surrounding area during the four years
of the conflict with the war right on
their doorstep every person in Carthage
was forced to choose science Pro and
anti Confederacy factions developed with
tensions escalating every single day it
has been reported that a team
bell acted as a spy for the Confederacy
and even that she joined Quantrill's
Raiders both suggestions are unlikely
however any news that she may have
gotten about a Union troop movements she
would no doubt have passed on but in
June 1864 Budd was shot and killed by
Union soldiers in Sarcoxie Missouri when
they surrounded a house that he was in
desperate to prevent any further tragedy
the family packed up and they moved to
Texas it turns out they got out of
Carthage just the right time three
months later it was burned to the ground
by Confederate rebels determined to
drive Union soldiers out of the town
Bell drove one of the family's wagons as
they wound their way down from Missouri
to a small town ten miles southeast of
Dallas called Syene things didn't go
nearly as well for the Shirley's in
Texas as they had gone in Missouri
John had hoped to reinvest in a hotel
that those plans didn't work out and he
was forced to return to farming
conflicts arose with the locals who
accused John of taking more than his
share of water from the communal well
Belle was enrolled at the local one-room
schoolhouse her attendance however it
was pretty erratic this was probably
just because she was bored of the
material having already covered it when
she was in Carthage
[Music]
while back in Carthage bail had come
across a boy by the name of John Reed
Reed's who was two years older than
Belle joined Quantrill's Raiders when he
was 17 he was tall and stocky and his
ability with his fists and a gun had and
in the respect of the other members of
the gang
Belle admired him from afar but her
family moved away before a relationship
could develop Belle was ecstatic to
learn that sometime around 1865 the
reeds had also relocated to Texas they
quickly became a couple and on the 1st
of November 1866 they were married Belle
was 18 at the time Jim and Mel they
moved in with the shirley family where
Jim helped out on the family farm Jim
didn't take to farm work and he tried
his hand as a salesman he worked for a
saddle maker in Dallas selling saddles
and bridles for a time by the ends of
1867 however Jim's family had moved back
to Missouri Ian Bell decided to join
them the reeds set themselves up on a
farm in Bates County Jim worked the
lands with his brothers then in
September of 1868 Bell gave birth to a
daughter Rosie lead from the start Bell
took to calling the baby her little
pearl soon after this everyone was
calling the Maggie pal the first
opportunity that John and Eliza Shelley
had to see their granddaughter was when
Belle returned to Texas to attend the
funeral of her younger brother Edie
the events surrounding the murderer
cloudy but it appears that he was
involved in horse theft following the
funeral and reunion with a parent's belt
returned to the reed farm in Missouri
her relationship with Jim it was
strained he spent less and less time on
the farm and more and more time at the
horse racing track
it was while at the races that Jim ran
into a man named Tom star the star was
half Cherokee outlaw who made a living
by selling whiskey in Indian Territory a
practice which happened to be a federal
crime star ran the enterprise with his
sons and they were soon joined by Jim
reet
Jim's foray into the outlaw worlds it
escalated dramatically when his brother
Scott was murdered Jim vowed revenge and
hunted down the killer dispatching both
him and his brother Bell now found
herself with a husband he was being
hunted by not just the law but also the
Friends of the man who had killed we
don't know what he did there to support
the family but suspicions are strong
that it was through such nefarious means
as stagecoach robbery and gambling On
February the 22nd 1871 Bell gave birth
to a second child a boy who
named James Edwin nicknamed Eddie only a
month later jim was accused of a
counterfeit money scam and was forced to
gain to relocate his family when the LA
authorities began looking into his case
they discovered that he was also wanted
for murder Jim skips down and made his
way and horse back to Texas bail and the
two children they followed him by
stagecoach in March 1871 bail turned up
at the family farm in Texas with two
kids and two wanted husbands Belle's
father helped them set up on a small fan
near Coon Creek in Boss County but Jim
read that are any proven that he was no
farmer soon the farm was attracting a
regular assortment of vagabonds who
would sit around with Jim and plan out
their various crimes Jim became involved
in livestock rustling when he learns
that a local man by the name of dick
crave he had four thousand dollars in
cash stashed in his home Jim and his
brother Sol couldn't resist the
temptation however the robbery was
botched and they ended up murdering
crazy a few months later the brothers
were accused of murdering another man
this man whose last name was wheeler had
apparently reported to the authorities
what he knew about the Reid mobs illegal
activities he was found in this tongue
cut out this latest outrage resulted in
both Jim and Sol having a $500 reward
placed on their capture dead or alive
and of course it was time to move once
again leaving the children with Mel's
parents the couple headed into Choctaw
Indian Territory where the authorities
would be unable to follow them
Jim was unable to stay out of trouble
like on November 19 1873 along with two
accomplices he rode to the farm of a
wealthy retired judge who lived near the
South Canadian River the judge and his
wife
they were hung from a tree and forced to
divulge the location of the cash in the
house the bandits they got away with a
huge sum of $30,000 by now the strain on
the marriage it was simply too much Mel
was fed up with the life of crime that
her husband had forced her into she
packed up and she took the children back
to the family farm in Syene Reed's
headed for San Antonio where he took up
with a woman named Rosa mccomus he
continued his outlaw ways but fate
caught up with him when a former
associate shot him in the back on August
the 6th 1874
[Music]
Bell was now a widow and she had two
young children to take care of she
stayed on the family farm with her
parents in 1876 John Shirley died this
forced Eliza to sell the farm and
relocate to Dallas Bell and the children
they went with her allegedly Bell was
briefly married for three weeks -
Charles younger uncle of Cole Younger in
1878 but this is not substantiated by
any evidence it's just a rumor On June
the 5th 1880 Bell married Sam Starr the
son of her husband's former associate
Tom Starr and they settled in the Indian
territory there she learned ways of
organizing planning and fencing for the
rustlers horse thieves and bootleggers
as well as harboring them from the law
at 23 the half Cherokee Sam was nine
years younger than his new bride they
moved into Cherokee Nation territory and
settled into a homestead some 760 miles
southwest of Fort Smith they cleared
three acres of land and planted corn
there were plenty of fish in the nearby
river and game was also plentiful it
seems like the ideal existence and it
could have been if Belle's past hadn't
gotten in the way former associates of
Jim Reed they began to learn that Belle
had a hideout in Indian Territory which
was safe from the reach of the law so
many of these outlaws started showing up
that Belle was forced to convert a
nearby cave into a sort of robbers roost
with three log cabins being erected up
until now Belle had managed to keep
herself from any actual involvement in
illegal activity this changed in 1882
when she and Sam asked a neighbor if
they could put some horses in his pen
prior to selling them the neighbor
agreed but on inspection pointed out
that at least two of the horses belonged
to other local farmers salmon Belle
ignored the claims and went ahead and
sold the horses when the original owners
of the stone and horses found out they
pressed charges
salmon Belle they were handed an
indictment to appear before the court on
the charge of larceny Sam's father Tom
he put up bail for the couple both Belle
and Sam they were found guilty
Sam was given a years prison time in
Detroit Michigan while Belle was
sentenced to two concurrent six-month
spells at the same facility with their
mother and stepfather in jail that
children were farmed out to family and
friends Sam and Belle they were model
prisoners earning themselves an early
release after nine months they settled
back into life on the farm and things
they were pretty quiet for a few months
then in December of 1884 a former
associate of Jim Reed by the
name of Jim Middleton turns up looking
for a place of refuge from the law
Middleton was wanted for murder ins that
law they were pretty hot on his trail
Middleton hung around the area for
several months then one day balance and
ranch was raided by law enforcement
officers from Lamar County the officers
had received permission from the
Cherokee Nation leaders to conduct the
rate Middleton was not at the residence
at the time but the raid scared him
enough to make him want to make a run
for it but with the law so close on his
trail they couldn't figure out a way to
get out of the area without being
detected bail came to his rescue though
suggesting that she drive a wagon with
the children in tow to visit relatives
in Arkansas Middleton was hide in the
wagon covers and make his getaway when
they were clear of prying eyes the plan
it was working well and after some time
Middleton was ready to light out on his
own
however 17 year-old pearl refused to let
him take a horse this led to 14 year old
Eddy heading off to the nearest farm and
attempted to buy a horse he came back
with a broken-down half blind math it
was hardly the ideal getaway transport
versus it was all the Middleton had and
when he sat up on his own with Bell's
Colt 45 as his only protection five days
later the horse was found in some scrub
on a riverbank not far from Fort Smith
then on May the 11th 1885 Middleton's
body was found a couple of hundred yards
downstream the authorities soon traced
the gun that was in his holster back to
Bell they also discovered that the horse
though legitimately purchased by Eddy
had previously been stolen the end
result was that Bell was once again up
on charges of larceny this time around
Bell was found not guilty
however she returned home only to
discover that a husband Sam had been
wounded in a shootout with the Indian
police Sam had now become ensconced in
his own life of crime fearful of the
rough justice that Indian police were
likely to dish out Bell convinced him to
hand himself in to the federal
authorities Sam was indicted for trial
in February of 1887 and then released on
bail on December 17th Sam Bell and the
children attended a party at a
neighbor's house everything it was
laughter and merriment until Frank West
the local law officer turned up he and
Sam got into an argument that soon
devolved into a gun battle in the
minutes both of the men were dead
[Music]
Bell star was now widowed for the second
time Sam's death made possession of the
ranch on Cherokee land a bit of a
problem they had not bought the land it
was in their possession because of Sam's
Indian blood now that he was dead
however Belle's right of possession was
disputed with pressure mounting on her
to get out of Cherokee territory
she decided there was another solution
she married Sam's brother bill July
alias Jim Starr and with that she was
once again married to a Cherokee and so
she had possession rights to the land
now 39 bill was 15 years older than her
third husband the marriage of
convenience
it was not pleasing to pearl age 19 or
Eddie age 17 both of them constantly
argued with the Jim which was a source
of ongoing frustration for them around
this time pearl fell in love with a
young man who in the course of time
approached belt you asked her consent to
marry her daughter Bell flatly refused
giving the reason that she had long told
pearl that she could only marry a man
who had at least $25,000 worth of
property she later tried to trick the
young man by sending him a letter with
pearls forged signature on it stating
that she had married someone else the
young couple though they soon figured
out the ruse and continued to see each
other behind Belle's back before long
pearl became pregnant Bell she was not
happy giving her daughter two options
have an abortion or never bring the
child into her presence pearl chose the
latter option giving birth to a girl
called Flossie on April the 22nd 1887
she took the baby to live with her
paternal grandparents in 1887 Jim was
arrested for horse theft by this time
however belt was making an effort to go
straight she had stopped allowing
fugitives to use her place as a hideout
when it came time for Jim's trial she
refused to assist in his defense
meanwhile young Eddie star was having
his own problems he was shot while
trying to steal a horse belt feared that
he would die she sent a message to pearl
telling her that she had better come
back to see her brother for the last
time she added however that she was not
to bring the baby pearl returned to see
Eddie who recovered from his injury Bell
put pressure on her daughter to give up
Flossie for adoption during the visit
pearl outrightly refused but Bell was a
stubborn woman she maneuvered things
behind the scenes and Flossie was taken
from Pearl and placed into an orphanage
in November of
in 88 edu is now up on horse theft
charges of his own again bail refused to
participate in the defense
Eddie's trial it was scheduled for march
of 1889 he returned to the family
homestead and reportedly threatened to
kill his mother he then took off never
to see bail again Belle's problems
escalated when a couple the Watsons
turned up at the farm looking for
sharecropping work Belle decided to take
them up on their offer beans and some
extra money
Belle became quite friendly with mrs.
Watson on one occasion the woman
revealed that her husband was actually
wanted for murder
this caused warning bells in Belle's
mind if the cherokee tribal council
found out that she was again harboring
fugitives they would surely kick her off
the land they offered to give the
Watsons their sharecropping feedback in
order to get them to leave but Edgar
Watson he refused it was only when Belle
revealed that she knew that Watson was a
wanted man that he left taking up with
his wife in a nearby tenant cabin
[Music]
on July the 2nd 1889 Bell and a young
husband Jim they left on horseback to
meet Jim's trial appointment at Fort
Smith Belle's intention was to accompany
him halfway pay a debt at a store on
King's Creek and then return home they
stayed the night with friends and 20
miles from Fort Smith the next morning
Belle Town for home while Jim carried on
to the fort Belle stopped off at King's
Creek where she had lunch at the local
store further along the trail she stops
at the home of a man named Jackson wrote
this was a popular meeting place for
locals she hoped to see her son Eddie
who had been staying there but he left
before she arrived present though was
Edgar Watson the sharecropper who Belle
had forced off her land as he saw Belle
arrive he promptly left after a short
time eating and conversing with friends
Belle got back in a horse and continued
towards home however she never made it
she was blasted from her horse by a
shotgun blast the killer then approached
the dying figure on the grounds and
blasted again Belle's panicked horse it
galloped for home the concerned pal set
out to find her mother by the time she
got to the murder site a young boy had
already found the body Belle was taken
to a farmhouse barely alive pearl was
just in time to be alongside her at the
moment that her mother took her last
breath the question of who killed Belle
Starr has intrigued historians for well
over a century both of her children have
been suspects Eddy had threatened his
mother at least once after she had
disciplined him with a bullwhip that the
most likely candidate is Edgar Watson
Watson was actually put on trial for the
murder however the evidence was deemed a
circumstantial and he was acquitted he
eventually returned to Florida where he
was killed in a shootout with a posse no
other efforts were ever made to track
down the killer of Belle Starr there
were several other potential suspects
besides Watson including July himself
apparently July had been caught with the
young Cherokee girl and Belle had been
making his life hell just a few weeks
after Belle's death July was mortally
wounded by a deputy who was on his trail
so the facts of Belle Starr's life but
not exactly as exciting or as outlandish
as the fictionalized version that began
with the dime novel Belle Starr the
Bandit Queen or the female Jesse James
in 1889 in summarizing her life for a
fort psmith
elevator reporter about a year before
her death Mel said I regard myself as a
woman who has seen much of
if the reality was that she was not the
female Jesse James she wasn't even a
Bandit Queen what she was was a twice
widowed woman with two children who did
what she could to survive only today to
be shot down in cold blood as is a story
of hardship and tragedy in the real Old
West her gravesite is near her lake
Oklahoma a horse was engraved on her
tombstone along with these words shed
not for her the bitter tear nor give the
heart to vain regret tis but the casket
that lies here the gem that filled it
sparkles yet so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did give
us a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe if you're looking for
something else to watch right now they
check out a video from the archives link
to you on the screen or if you look into
something completely different to watch
why not check out another channel I do
called top 10s find a link to that below
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]